post-marriage Society
because on one hand we hear that women
should wait till they're married to have
sex but at the same time we also hear
from the men that they don't want to get
married anymore
so what do we do with that seems like
it's true because nowadays A lot of
people are looking at marriage as a
contract rather than a partnership
there's a huge difference between that
because with a contract there are so
many terms and many headaches and this
and that I know it is a contract
yeah but that's because that is what it
is now because realistically the
traditional sense of marriage is not a
contract really in terms of the law once
the law is involved that's when
everything when tits up I think yeah so
the problem is is that there's zero
advantage to marriage in the western
world for a man there are zero
statistical Advantage if you use your
mind if you use your head instead of
your heart and you look at the
advantages of getting married there are
absolutely not really none because this
new idea of new age feminism just
basically destroys all men and the idea
in the event of her leaving
and and it's very common that women
leave right let's let's stop the a man
versus woman attack et cetera Etc life's
difficult for everybody we all have
different challenges different things to
go through but if a woman marries a man
and it goes wrong she has emotional
heartbreak fine but if a man marries a
woman and it goes wrong he has emotional
heartbreak plus everything he has ever
worked for is ripped out from underneath
him and he has to give that chick money
forever and some places you don't even
have to be married exactly that's why
the men don't want to live with the
women that's right so when you make
these rules and these laws right under
the guise of feminism and equality all
this garbage all you're doing is scaring
men away from commitment and then you
have to add in the other hidden element
and the other hidden element is what I
said earlier is whose fault a lot this
is is promiscuous women right so when
Society is broken down if women were
saying if all women got together and
said we'll only have sex after marriage
guess what men would do get married but
you don't right so now you're in Miami I
go Miami I can [ __ ] anything in the club
I don't have to marry any of them if I
marry them I get wrecked so like let's
all use our Springs here what am I gonna
do well I'm gonna be like well no bounce
see uh no no so men have been scared
away from the idea of marriage and
that's a law that is the fault of this
new [ __ ] law and this new feminism
and this new crap they don't give men
any tactical advantage and I'm talking
about small things a man's not even
allowed to be a man in his own house do
you know in England you'll get accused
of emotional abuse I can marry a woman
not lay a hand on her I can just raise
my voice to her that's emotional abuse I
can raise my voice to her because she's
going out drinking with dudes she can go
out drinking six nights of night and
week with men and I can say what the
[ __ ] are my wife sit down she can call
the cops call me emotionally abusive I
get arrested now now there's a court
case against me I have to go to court
and defend myself she'll divorce me take
my house I have to sell my car because
she's drinking vodka with [ __ ] God
knows who but you know it's Insanity
what do you think of what do you think
of Child Support
and that's another interesting thing
because a lot of these arguments it's
it's it it goes beyond man and woman and
it goes into the the larger sphere as a
whole right because we talked earlier
about war and how a lot of men used to
die and that doesn't happen anymore so
what you used to have in societies and
I'm not saying I have all the answers
I'm just commenting right what you used
to have in societies is a bunch of men
would die at War because men have more
dangerous lives than women there'd be a
bunch more women than men the top G's
would impregnate a bunch of women and
the top G's could take care of the women
and not be etc etc that's now changed
right so the reason a lot of the reason
that monogamy is pushed is because it's
good for society and it is good for
society it's good for society as a whole
to have a man a woman a family together
the man provides for the woman Etc the
government doesn't want to pay for all
these kids if you don't have child
support he's paying for these kids the
government does it it breaks down right
so that's why child support is enforced
in many parts of the world in certain
other parts of the world child support
isn't enforced because they have
religious beliefs or genuine genuine
family beliefs that keep the families
together but in the Western World now
you need child support because you've
broken things down to the point where
men don't want to be married to chicks
chicks don't want to listen to the man
the man can't even be the man in his own
household he can't even feel respected
where he goes his woman gives her him no
status and and now he doesn't want to
[ __ ] deal with her anymore so how do
you get that kid paid for well then tell
the man or you go to jail and you just
come along with a [ __ ] long arm of
the law and you [ __ ] him and so yeah
it's difficult it's hard to answer yeah
but it's hard to answer the true answer
to all of it is an idealistic answer I
don't like to think idealistically and
talk idealistically but it's the truth
the true answer to it is to instill in
the man a sense of Duty in which he
wants to take care of his woman
regardless because that's his child but
you will do that I'll tell you how you
do that you do that by inspiring out of
the man by being a very good woman so
I'll give you an example if I had a
child with a woman and she was always a
great woman to me she was never she
never cheated on me she was a good woman
to me and I was running around being
whatever and she's like look I just
can't put up with you anymore you're top
G you're going to do what you're going
to do I'm gonna look after your kid I'm
gonna you can see him anytime you want I
care about you please
don't leave me in poverty I'd say cool
100 I'm like I'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my God that's like a real man though
because I was in a situation just yeah
but I was just in a situation like that
to where it's like hearts don't break
even and that's the reality too it's
like if those morals and principles are
not instilled in a man none of that [ __ ]
matters so obviously the child support
stuff obviously hits close home to me
because I'm already 50 000. it's just in
lawyer fees trying to get him to provide
yeah you know what I mean and it sucks
because it's like you play in the NBA
like why couldn't you why don't you want
to do more and it's just because again
of the relationship it's personal it's
not about ourselves that's right so it's
like yeah if you're not so I just I just
feel like it's like why do you get money
for making a poor choice well it wasn't
a poor choice because I'm not trying to
like disrespect you in any way it's just
like if you left and so it's yeah an eye
for it just right because we because we
made a commitment so we made it at the
end of the day we made a commit we have
a forever commitment [ __ ] marriage we're
we are forever fan family so again as
someone who is literally going through
this if I made more money than him I
would be paying him child support and
that would be fair to me but this is
what's really interesting what's truly
interesting is if you go to other
countries and I'm talking about
civilized countries right if you go to
Poland or Czech Republic or whatever
these countries which are in many
metrics more civilized than the West
they're safer to live in they're cleaner
Etc there's no child support laws so if
you have a divorce the man just takes
care of the woman because that's his kid
and that's just what he's supposed to do
and that's just it so what you're saying
is he you're right about the man having
the morality instilled inside of them
and my point is that the reason a lot of
this doesn't exist the reason men don't
have morality installed in them is not
just about the individual case of the
man it's about society as a whole it's
about women as a whole men as a whole
the dating game as a whole the life he's
living as a whole and and it's and this
is the world we live in that's why I was
talking about how dangerous new think is
because now we have this new thing this
new world and we're living in this new
world and the truth is
as a man now your the game has changed
in the game of chess sometimes it's not
about winning it's about making sure you
don't lose if you cannot lose if you
could not blunder any pieces and protect
your king long enough you'll win the
game and there's a lot of men who are
now like okay how do I not lose well you
know what I become [ __ ] ruthless
that's how I don't lose I get I get all
my sex because the women are promiscuous
I get laid as much as I want I don't let
anyone [ __ ] tie me into anything dumb
any [ __ ] wants to get fresh to me or
[ __ ] talk to another dude I cut her
off financially but man you just forget
ruthless so you don't lose the game but
that's because the game's been rigged
against men so the harder you rig the
game against us the more ruthless we're
gonna have to be to compete and that's
it's unfortunate I'm not saying I have
the answers I'm just saying why men do
what they do Brittany I just think that
with regards to child support you've got
a kid you look after it and I do I don't
know
that's what I said no that's why I said
with regards to the child support that's
what I first said I think that you have
a kid that you should look after it I
don't agree that I don't agree with men
giving the women money but I think it's
disgusting that a man can have a child
and not support him so so why but this
is another thing so this is this is the
comments we have to make right because
we don't have all the answers we have to
make the comments on it this goes into
the deeper point every time a court
rules in favor of a chick having a
hundred thousand dollars a month that
puts men off to a level like it's fine
if there was a baseline child support
thousand dollars a month two thousand
dollars a month that's so if you have a
kid Baseline regardless of income if
your man wants to give you more he does
if he doesn't whatever whatever but when
you come along start saying this percent
of a man's income do you have an idea
how scary that is to a man who works for
his money he works for his money and you
know why it's scary it's not just
because he's giving his money away it's
because he knows he isn't giving money
to the kid yeah the kid you can raise a
kid on 500 bucks a month in most of the
world you want that kid in Gucci you and
Gucci you in a nice car going on dates
with another dude with my money you
could I'd rather burn the [ __ ] house
down and give it to you
for child support I just think it
incentivizes poor decisions like I
haven't gotten pregnant by someone but
like you someone but I'm saying but like
you're gonna you're gonna pay someone
who's done that like why did they get oh
no but I'm literally I'm literally
telling you that what if I made more
money than him I would have no problem
paying for my child and their child
child support laws vary in different
states so in North Carolina for instance
if you make over combined over 300 000 a
year then you are considered Off the
Grid so then you have to prove this is
how much my your rent is any bill that
my son occupies I get a percent that I
get a percentage of so on the low end it
would be 50 if there's a big enough
salary Gap it could be up to 97 in the
court the judge gets to decide what
makes the most sense so if my child's
father makes 20 million dollars a year
from basketball he gets to decide if six
thousand dollars is a lot if eight
thousand or ten thousand whatever but
you have to prove that so it's not like
you just it's enough money for a Chanel
bag like these are a my son watches
Peppa Pig that's a part of that's a
cable bill you know what I mean so it's
it's a percentage of everything so
you're not like just living living it up
you're just living so you're able to
there's a roof up in your son's head my
whole point is that like it's all down
to choices and the man made a choice too
because I can't get pregnant unless he
nuts it I I understand that but I'm
and I didn't take a penny from him and
the government wanted me to but I
decided that now that he was better off
that my child I look after him myself
anything he wants to give his son if he
wanted to is extra but I worked hard and
I've done it all on my own because it
was this list because it's this headache
is this no and I know a lot of women
that went there though that you you have
to think that he's not going to be a man
and take care of his child don't you
think that's unfair on you no because my
children he's happy now I'm gonna give
him what he wants a child as well he
made that child
what are we talking about I'm saying
right now it's not fair because women
have abortion that's legal it's not
legal for them oh no say it they get no
sand and the same thing with birth I
mean I could have done but it wasn't
worth my time
wanted the child though that's exactly
my thing
with an example my whole point my point
I think he should I think he should take
care of it I just don't agree with
having legal incentives for women to
leave that's my point he should give you
money for the kid if you have a kid you
should but I just don't agree with with
see but the thing is if men stood up and
became fathers to their children women
control we're in control of who we sleep
with so at the end
of you but you pick who you sleep with
so if you pick a guy that's getting
girls pregnant but she doesn't know that
he's not gonna be there she doesn't know
that if she married him she'd be all
right she trusted this man to be your
father to a child and now she's left
with a child and No One's Gonna support
her don't you think that song should
have married him first I mean you can
get married
this is what solves problems
please don't cut me off this is the
problem yeah stop acting like every
woman that leaves a marriage and gets
divorced is because she's this and she's
that there's a lot of women that suffer
they actually need the support and the
legal incentives so that they know when
they leave somebody can back them up
because they'll be on their own stop
acting like men are angels because
there's a lot of men that are dealing
with a lot of the traumas that they have
from a manual being difficult the same
way that Andrew Tech explained a man's
world is highly competitive men are out
there suffering it is hard to be a man
and a lot of the time the person takes
the brunt of it is the woman so yes
she's well within her right to leave
take her child and be in a better place
and the government should step in to
make sure that that man that made her
make that decision steps in for that kid
wait the time that she takes to take
care of the child is the time that she
doesn't have to go to work so she's
already done on income and she's having
to be taking care of the child on her
own that don't make sense not every man
is a bloody Angel you know every woman
is a devil
right so now it's my time to talk talk
what I was saying to her is right is
that if she got married first
then should have been all right she'll
have to be fighting for the court so the
same law that you're saying would have
supported her and her child there is a
difference between getting married first
that's what I'm saying and that's what
gives you more money
good decision yeah excuse me but I shut
up when you were talking no one
apologies
so what I was trying to say is that
there was an incentive when women get
married first and have children because
I'm not saying that I'm not saying that
you I'm just saying women in general if
a woman gets married first before she
has a child and then it leaves then it's
totally different like he said before
she set up for life and she believes
she's out for life so if somebody else
without marriage though that's the point
you want to hear no and as a person
again let's ask somebody who's actually
going through it because none of you
[ __ ] know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about when it comes to child
support lawyers none of that [ __ ] none
of you [ __ ] know okay so you don't
the reality is if I would have gotten
married and did everything right and did
everything the moral way right guess
what all I would have a dish on top of
what I'm going through with child
support is alimony so I'm still in the
courts fighting whether I'm married or
whether I'm not so that I get what
you're saying because you at least get
the commitment to you know maybe back up
that he's gonna be there but it doesn't
ensure anything everybody wants a
[ __ ] guaranteed thing there's no
guaranteed in life we're talking
different places when you're in America
and you're married and you divorce
you've still gotta fight for your money
not in England in England you get a
lawyer and it's sorted that's the
difference but you don't have to be
going there saying oh I need this for my
child and I need this you get once you
get divorced and you go to court it's
that much I'm saying she just spent 50
000 pounds she's still fighting you have
to pay that here you would not have to
pay that yeah
you would not have to pay the hair do
your research you would not have to pay
that here well you get divorced she
wouldn't be going for all the battle
that she's going it'd be simpler in
England to get divorced than in America
in England take your money don't get mad
area you have a parental partnership
I just want to make a point you know
what you were saying get married even
Tate said himself men don't want to get
married anymore he's saying why are you
not twisting what you're saying he's not
even listening to what he's saying
anymore
and you're twisting it to suit yourself
take didn't you say that men are scared
of getting married now what yeah okay
but why because like you said with child
support they feel like there's no
Advantage
it's not that simple because men don't
want to marry you okay so let's let's
analyze that point and first and first
thing back to the child support thing
what's actually interesting to talk
about is there's a lot of countries in
the world where there is no child
support system and it functions right so
you have to if you want to pay attention
to actually you know learn about society
as a whole it's very interesting to
study all the different societies and
economies in which there is no child
support and and children don't die I
mean people get divorced and they still
find a way to function and it's
interesting it's a very long
conversation because it extrapolates
about how the whole society works as a
whole that's the first point second
thing I'll actually sit here and argue
the point that I don't think any man
really ever wants to get married I think
that women convince them to get married
and I think that any woman who is
genuinely serious about convincing her
man to get married could do it
I don't think in the modern world at
least men wake up and go can't wait to
get married but what they do is they get
a chick who's so good and ticks so many
boxes and makes them so happy and she'll
sit there and say you know what it would
mean the world to me
please and he'll go off for [ __ ] sake
all right then and that's what happens
so I still think you can convince 99.9
of men to marry you the point I was
making is the society Society isn't
convincing the man to marry you it's not
like it used to be where the man
believed he had to be married Society
has done the opposite so it's your job
as a woman to make it clear to him that
it is worthwhile once again
how would you convince a man it's
worthwhile for him to say that's my wife
status that's how you do it this is the
under a misunderstood hack to to men as
a whole is status if you could say if
you can convince that man by marrying
you his status will increase amongst his
peers he's going to do it and for anyone
out here who disagrees with me the
things men do for status let's actually
analyze how Baseline men are what is
status is respect right men kill over
respect men gangs kill each other over
respect a man will smash another man's
face in for insulting him we will die
for respect in stairs you told me we
won't get married we'll die for her
we'll go to the front line of a war and
the only reason we don't walk away and
abandon our post as artillery shells let
rain is because we're afraid of being
mocked for being a coward we'll die for
status so status is what it's all about
it's what it's always been about if you
want a man to marry you status and it's
the same thing with nearly anything you
want to do with a man I don't know
anything about your personal life I'll
be honest I don't know right but I'll
tell you this now if this dude send me a
player believed that he would be higher
respected amongst his peers and among
Society for taking care of you properly
that's what he [ __ ] do he doesn't
feel that because either he's rolling
with the wrong people or you've pissed
him off in a way or something Publix
happened I don't have a clue but
something's happened where he feels like
if I take care of her I'll look like a
[ __ ] that's what he's scared of if it
was inversed he had no problem giving
you money because that's how men
function I'm telling you right now as a
man I'm telling you what I would do if I
had a chick with a woman right and she
went on the news Talk Jesus and [ __ ]
and this like I said I have no idea what
you've done but I was given my personal
made-up scenario shooting on the news
Talk Jesus and he [ __ ] lied to me
he's a piece of [ __ ] and then I bought
her a Bentley Williams we're like well
look she insults topped you she insults
him and he's [ __ ] he's a sin but if
she was like you know what he he's
misunderstood he's a good guy it just
didn't work out but she'd be in a
mansion right and would that be me being
a nice guy caring about her or let's be
honest would it be me being a selfish
piece of [ __ ] dude and say what makes me
look better man are all about status is
how we function it's how we function as
a whole so Society this is where it
extrapolates it gets interesting when
Society with this new think has
destroyed all of the Baseline Humanities
and Baseline understandings of how men
interact with women and now all the
things we previously understood about
what made a good man what made a good
woman and how we should act together and
how we should interact has been erased
of course men are acting like [ __ ]
and of course women are doing wrong
things nothing makes sense anymore
you've taken the chess board and moved
all the [ __ ] pieces around nobody
gets it it should be very simple I'm a
man I work hard I take care of my woman
I'm the man of the house she treats me
with respect she would never insult me
or raise her voice to me in front of
other people she's a problem she brings
it to me in private we act as a team we
work together if we break up she was a
good woman to me she fulfilled her roles
the best she possibly could I'm still a
man I'm gonna take care of her but all
of that is gone all of it's gone all of
it and it's gone because of all the
ideas we were discussing earlier the
feminism the new age [ __ ] [ __ ]
dudes left and right and Center all
these things all these Baseline things
have eroded Society to the point where
now you have men ignoring their paternal
Instinct you have men who will sit there
and go that's my child but [ __ ] her
that that is that that's actually a
massive observation to make about how
[ __ ] up Society is and it's all and it
shouldn't be that way because men in a
lot of the world are not like that
because so you have to look at all these
small things the small things we talk
about it's no big deal she goes on boats
in Miami it's no big deal it is a big
deal because now that dude ain't gonna
want to [ __ ] pay child support
because you were on those [ __ ] boats
with this [ __ ] the other team
do you think do you think that men not
as well say Sagittarius thank you very
much do you think that men marry for
like high status families like I'm
thinking of like Ivanka Trump like with
someone as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible